hello there reject nation thank you guys
so much for clicking on this video we
have made it to the umbrella academy
season three finale yeah this last half
has been awesome it has just been
getting progressively more awesome and
engaging and shocking and revelatory but
loving it i've been loving it if you
have if you're just having a click on
here not watching or once just started
like episode five or six man
i feel like there's like some really
good stuff in the first half but they're
great stuff
has been like pretty solid from the in
the last half yeah guys uh leave a like
uh that helps sign the algorithm and
subscribe and click the notification
bell in case something else pops up on
this channel that you're like yeah i
want to check that out and full length
watch alongs where you sync up with the
time code are available for our super
sexy rejects over at our patreon page
thank you all who have joined for
umbrella academy thus far we cover a
bunch of shows over there as well where
some shows have exclusive reaction
highlights included and uh the team of
prepper thank you guys for helping us
edit down these highlights and thank you
aaron again for joining me on this
journey now you're the only one i know
that in in real life
watches umbrella academy so no one else
would rather watch it with and uh yeah
guys let's see what ends up happening in
this episode i can't wait to find out
hopefully it sticks the landing all
right let's get to it
[Music]
i lost
the other side where's klaus children
i'm sorry but your brother
i did all i could
but it didn't make it through
in
in
time
the best minds of the age theorize we
live in a clockwork cosmos
in the quantum age
time and space are suspected to be a
holograph
ancient people what
makes you feel tiny huh why would you
put pineapple on a pizza
we are just
tiny specks of sand
true
where exactly are we i'm dead man
we're dead
welcome to my hood
welcome to my hood oh where's the
umbrella it was on the flag ah i caught
it nice i looked for it now that people
braided us
[Laughter]
covered our asses nice does anyone know
what that sign says yeah it says do not
ring the bell what do we do
does anybody know
reggie
reggie sweden
calling her dad by his first name oh my
gosh
dad killed me
oh my god he killed me too a lot
he's an alien we're trying not to use
that kind of terminology here
you could just say
he's
british
all my life i've been a loser i've been
a freak i've
made mistake after mistake after mistake
it was a sign that this is my home
it's where i meant to be
this shitty place
we're dead right as the duggy baby
that's the dougie so what happens if i
do this
nice try big guy but there ain't no pain
in the boy
yeah take your best shot
like how this that looks like a 1950 set
i can see it i don't get it like we're
with the people that loved us the most
okay so why wouldn't we tell them things
suck right now and it would be nice to
give the family something to fight for
you shut up and eat your fish
are you lying again no she's not
okay
she's just scared she doesn't want to be
seen as weak are you really sure that he
could kill luther i think he could kill
luther klaus and the rest of us without
breaking a moral sweat
and what's worse i think allison is
involved no no
god i love you five always the smartest
look even if you're right i can't
imagine they're just gonna come clean if
we confront them
i agree
i like how his voice has been coming
deeper
victor
relax don't worry you have all the time
in the world to get over it
all right that's it
what the hell
oh
this is someone's idea of heaven
hey buddy
[Laughter]
this is fun
we're gonna see you open up now
he's still thinking about that bachelor
party
still getting invited we're here now in
the hotel oblivion just like you wanted
i made that happen don't be ridiculous
allison killed harlan and i united the
families what did you do number two
the bells are just a metaphor for this
sergio correct number five um
great so we'll just stay in the hotel
forever staring at the walls and eating
bad sushi finding the sigil is our only
way out of here and the best chance we
have of resetting the universe funny how
you and dad are on the same page again
[Laughter]
i forgot my journey go on i'll meet you
on fire
what's your plan
come on
summon the guardian you know your deal
is costing people their lives do you
really think that i made a deal with a
dad to kill luther and klaus
i'm done i mean ugh that part of her
story is true she did not technically
just listen to me
trying to be defensive to cover your ass
oh
this is five
whoa victor allison
what is this place you're the ones who
said to hell with family and the whole
universe i'm the only one fighting to
save both we just need to know what dad
is planning before more of us get killed
where the hell is five
he was right behind me
it's just so mysterious
[Laughter]
little fun house
what's going on
three
[Music]
who's number three i don't know
[Laughter]
why tell the truth when you can just
mind [ __ ] someone into getting what you
want without ever having to be truly
vulnerable do you know how crazy that is
what if i fail i'll baby like
my mum found me
mom
is behind that crazy [ __ ]
he's a good and decent person usually
one
come on
just gonna leave that in the ceiling he
was never a sparrow he was our dad and a
shitty one at that you don't need him
easy for you to say when you've already
got a new family the best part of that
family just died
can't believe i'm saying this i'm
actually glad to see you guys
oh problem dad
you
he missed me
wow
i wish i could explore this more my boy
but now isn't a good time you used me
you know to get the family unless he's
tripping you used me and then when i was
no more used to you just leave me to die
on the floor leave you to die i did you
a favor
i knew you'd find your way back to the
void where you belong
i do like it there
[Laughter]
those dollar stores which are quite
freeze
that's that
[Music]
what the hell is happening we should get
back to the lobby
yeah
which one of our moronic siblings do you
think rang the damn bell
who did it
there's multiple like ancient asian
warriors right
nice
nice show sweetie
you didn't do much homie oh [ __ ] me
go go go go go go go go go press a
button okay whoa what floor oh [ __ ]
anyone
oh i'm so scared
oh okay revenge looks good on her would
you shut up and help us kill this thing
oh he's got an axe again
the deadliest one of them all
okay just stand there that's cool too
did this for all of us lutheran class
too
what did he have for you
i need you to trust me
look at me if we get through this
everything's gonna be okay
what the hell is the deal
right just say it already
oh [ __ ] oh you're separated you're
screwed you're screwed dude allison
victor there's got to be some way to
navigate this i'm gonna guess has
something to do with the numbers
hey
hey what do you think you're doing i'm
protecting my family all right you
promised we'd always be together i know
i know
well what a hell of a shot the armor
it's like hitting somebody there's a
space between the bracket plates you
need to get behind me
let's kill this thing wait sloan
oh god
damn
[Music]
goddamn ben
finally
[Music]
oh there it is oh the seven oh [ __ ]
the seed jewel
we did it we completed the entire
mission
finally someone with a power worth
mimicking
lila some weird adr
right
i'll explain later
[ __ ]
from the trailer
and the thumbnail on netflix
oh yeah it's pretty cool let's see
what's happening
at least this time we're not aiming at
each other
[Music]
[Applause]
nice
oh wow you put a dent in that thing
a little bit more than that just do that
to every one of them
guys never separate
[Laughter]
claps
i'm still confused about how klaus got
there because doesn't he need to a body
to just roll with it right now all right
question later
[Laughter]
oh we look like hell oh you tried
killing the guardian we just did so did
we i told you to stay in the beach
that's toxic love for you i love you
[Laughter]
you brought us here to die that's not so
somewhere in this hotel is the key to
resetting the universe we just need to
find the city i don't care about your
sigil none of us do no we barely
survived that guardian with a stupid
helmet and a sickle
are they standing on it x marks the spot
who's on the back of the warrior there's
one left
i have to go after it because that
worked so well the first time no they're
standing on it
hey i found the sigil
oh
not five that's how he becomes old five
he lost it it's official
it'll be fine
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
what
[Music]
what the hell gross
it's all spongy huh
yeah that's gross
i left you to god the most precious
thing in the universe and what was it
you'll soon understand
you all will
i have a feeling we're not going to
learn
yeah he's a ghost oh no
he just animated him no
klaus
i can't
hold it
i will love you forever
oh
man oh wow
[Music]
oh if i was slow and i'd murder that
horror graves right now
he'll be
[Music]
that's so back the devil is in the lobby
floor it's the stars
seven points seven of us
no
not you
what the [ __ ] is going on
it's the only way to stop him
oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
what is happening
[Music]
why do you say not allison fascinating
what is happening
what is going on holy crap what is
happening
[Music]
what
this is wild particles inside their
bodies are the only things that fuel the
machine
clouds he won't stop until we're all
dead
god damn it allison
oh it's exposed did you see that what
hargraves
yeah
whoa what the hell
what the heck
yo
[Music]
what the hell is happening beam a signal
or some [ __ ] what's going on here also
don't
don't make me do this
do you trust me
no
i don't
what are you doing
you gotta be [ __ ] me you said oh god
if they're gonna throw the credits those
would be so mad bro
turn back in time
why this happening
i'm going to watch heavy spoilers video
[Laughter]
what is happening here
so confused
what's wrong
nothing baby
no just so happy to be home that's where
you're always meant to be
did she die
what is happening she got everything she
wanted or did she
cool
i hope the baby's okay
i know it looks strange
it's not all big guy huh
oh
[ __ ] and that looks like some weird cgi
[Laughter]
we're so used to seeing him all bulky
not gonna show sloane i got my arm back
oh no
wait where where's sloane oh she was uh
she was right behind me og timeline
i don't care about any resets all right
i want my wife back where is she fine
i'm glad you're alive but please take
your hand off me not until you give me
an answer okay screw this
oh
they lost their powers
okay
come on alakazam
no tattoos i'm out [ __ ] oh guys come
on we should stick together and figure
this what are we supposed to do live our
lives
you guys
are just a separate man you guys gotta
figure this
[Music]
oh my out it's whoa
it's like hard drives this planet my god
hargrave central
[Music]
we got his wife back was it all a plan
just to get her i think so
[Music]
wow
lots of wrap ahead around yeah
this is not the way i thought uh this
season would end
that's a lot of wtf questions
hi there so
here's the deal
i'm shooting on my phone because it's
like three in the morning and uh aaron
actually called me a few hours after we
were done
shooting um the final episode reaction
from umbrella cat i was like dude there
was a post credit scene i was like aw
crap did you already watch it he already
watched it
and uh he said it's super short but i
was like oh we've gotten this far so
might as well
do a quick reaction to it for you guys
in my little editing station here
as you can see i've added new stations
right where we film
but on the opposite side but let's see
what this is all about
okay we're back on the train
betty
that's it
i don't know what's making that
what
what does that mean
i have no idea what's making that
is that uh
is this the same bed from the sparrow
academy or is this like another ben
from the
uh like
this are there gonna be like two bends
is what i'm getting at
just the original bend that got to
survive i don't know what this means for
the future of umbrella academy
or for what it's setting up for season
four this the bed that gotta just live a
happy normal life and wasn't tortured
and traumatized to like every bed that
we know it i don't i don't know i'm very
clueless right now as to what to make of
this
anyway i'm glad i watched it though but
aaron was telling me he didn't know what
to make of this post credit scene either
so
regardless it does not affect our just
our very long in-depth thorough
discussion that we have
of the episode talk for a long time so
you know stick around if you're
interested in our actual review portions
of it because yeah there's a lot to say
but this is
this is a weird post credit scene i have
no idea what it it what it's implying
a lot of pondering a lot of uh
yeah i'm just kind of not left with a
feeling of like what the [ __ ] there's a
feeling of like what's going on but it's
also just like a
like a calming kind of like
like if the show got canceled after this
i'm like i guess is the end of the show
there's just they're human and they're
separated and but obviously there's
going to be another season but
yeah i just feel um
i don't even know what i feel
i thought it came from that was a great
finale became pretty haunting
yeah in the last like 20 minutes i was
like this is some haunting [ __ ] this is
this is uh
getting to the dark part of my soul
right now
a
hargraved utopia wow
evil mastermind an evil mastermind yeah
what was
since that was
yeah his plan was
he wanted real estate it's what he
wanted
he wanted to be a real estate mogul he's
just all about capitalism
that's all he cared about he really
wanted to win a monopoly to own land
but it all makes sense now with the
monocle
you're the monopoly man
this was all good this whole time oh man
oh shoot
i didn't know where it was going to go
in the end yeah no and when they're all
like [ __ ] harder
are they going to die right now and they
got enough energy to reset the universe
but in hargraves image like
but he died
i mean
yeah they're very recent like clear some
clear goddamn answers next
i don't know their powers like luther
looks so weird without his muscle suit
on
that's just the actor is so odd how does
he know so much how does heart graves
know so much i mean i know he's like an
alien who's like seen everything in
anything but it's it's fascinating we're
three seasons in there's still so much
mystery and it's like to the the world
of this character and it seemed like he
had to keep the wife alive
yeah well this is
incubated on the moon or some [ __ ] yeah
kept her body on the moon for the event
that you'd bring her back one day why
would that matter with resetting the
universe i don't know
i have no clue it doesn't make sense but
i'm curiou i feel like we're gonna get
the answers next season
hopefully
is there something to do with what
allison constructed with pushing the
button that was her wish fulfillment is
that why sloane's not alive but why
would
that make it in her in a hargrave's
image that doesn't make sense because it
seems like the deal struck is that
hargraves would get what he wants and
allison would get what she wants
yeah reconstructing the entire universe
because rey is a man from the 60s and
here he is now in present day that's
what i mean is like like with whatever
buttons he was touching
must have been like my plan allison's
plan
right yeah he designed it that way
but then luther gets to come back to
life like lizzy she must have wanted
that or they didn't have powers and all
that
kind of like a
kind of like a scarlet witch house of em
thing you know in a certain extent of
being like
mutants or bad
yeah so i want to come back normal so i
think the question was really jarring
seeing luther
i was like somebody looks like just
normal he looks very long there's a long
limb in the director just looks like i'm
so used to seeing him like oh buff and
[ __ ] but um
i mean yeah it can't be a show without
them without not having powers i mean i
feel like they could do that for a few
episodes right it's crazy because like
it it maintained that play-like quality
you know just like a lot of scenes of
just them together
debating conversing arguing up until
like the very end other than like it's
got the most action packed with the
oblivion hotel but even though it was
still like contained at the hotel and i
was like oh it is doing the thing i was
kind of saying that i was hoping the
show would do which keep it like very
personal and intimate
and then it became like the biggest
in like 10 seconds it was like this is
the biggest i've ever gotten this is
massive yeah they're always i'm up in
the ante with this show
um but yeah i mean i quite loved the
last half of this i liked the finale a
lot i did i don't know how people feel
about the finale in general but i i love
this finale i i think it was
i think the
moment in the garden was a bit rushed
the button
it's like luther running off
makes perfect sense to me yeah you gotta
go find this woman yeah yeah he's
panicked he wants to go find her like
everyone thinks back but nothing else
matters him like that makes sense but
everyone just like split up in like 30
seconds
like screw family i think you guys
probably want to figure this [ __ ] out
together right yeah
like we got a lot of we got a lot of
answers
[Laughter]
man it makes me wonder if
how they interesting enough i think this
is the only time
we've seen where it allows
them to have some sort of time jump
because each yeah yeah each the previous
season started from the moment the last
season ended yeah which kind of
frees them up to have a different
structure for whatever season four is
gonna be um
i have no idea yeah i don't read the
comics for this show so no i think it's
vastly different from the comics or like
the first like
couple of um arcs but yeah this is very
different from from what i read
good yeah looks less predictable yeah
yeah
everybody can enjoy it
even gerard way doesn't know what the
[ __ ] happening
and he wrote it
i can imagine a lot of people have
issues with that i imagine allison has
been quite a polarizing portrayal
yeah
yeah yeah yeah because the show never
quite brings you to a state of
understanding
i think i understood but i think the way
they showed her express her grief and
frustration
was a little extreme
and
i don't know if it was the writing
choices or the directing choices but
it's just like
in spite of all her pain i was i don't
like you
yeah i don't like the choices that
you're making
well it just seems so
i mean she seems human and
human i can't deny that
it's more of a mixed bag for me uh when
it comes to her like at times i i really
get it at times i'm like
your selfish ways are getting in the
[ __ ] way
yeah it really hovers back and forth
before me with her and maybe up even up
until this final decision moment yeah
like every like she does
feel like the show tried having a a
redeeming quality
by her
saving them from death
which is a solid recovery
um but the fact that she did
lie her way to this moment and was very
deceptive
because it seemed like hargraves really
did want to honor his deal
yeah with her yeah he's like don't even
step on the [ __ ] uh
what was it the sigil the science the
stars yeah they're like don't don't step
on it like it seems like he really was
it wasn't it was keen honoring his deal
and and uh
and so it's like clearly she like she
seems like she's the one who
lucked out the most in the end yeah i
think this deal
and how the it plays out by the
very end kind of makes me
really think about hargraves as a
character and who this universe is hard
graves is maybe just all versions of
them are the two versions we've seen
in that
this man is truly someone
who is about justifying
the ends just find the means because
somewhere in his
in his spell of sucking the life force
out of him he gave them new life a new
chance
to be something without the burdens of
what he's put upon them
in a new reality
this is an interesting book end because
it starts off in the season where
they're stranded
but they decide to
you know find new settlement together
yeah and this starts off with stranded a
new place but they're gonna just [ __ ]
off and go their separate ways yeah
like it's very different
um yeah and the other two
i do i i i am kind of bummed about
sloane
yeah i'm sure he'll find her you know
because there's what 47 babies something
like that did that still happen here
you know i don't know man
it's a lot of questions there's a lot of
questions yeah it kind of makes me
ponder
so first season
in the second season we go back in time
second season to season three we're in
an alternate timeline
so
this is seemingly multiverse we're going
into a whole new universe entire new
reality well this this is a reset
reset reboot yeah and i think that's
what the seven like i said like seven
you know being very symbolic for
like creation recreation so like
creating the universe
yeah and literally it is birthed into
his own image where
hargraves land you know yeah he is he is
like god and ruler over this
yeah it makes me wonder
well that's because i really started
like sloane that's why yeah especially
this last episode i was like
all right we got some real depth to you
now finally
you grieving and revenge and all that
like you're a real character yeah i gave
you something to root for for her for
sure i always liked her um but this was
like now i'm like really now i care for
you like when the
when it looked like the
warrior was gonna stab her was gonna
kill her i was like oh that's sad i was
like kind of bummed at the thought of
her dying
yeah i think she's i think she'll be
around yeah a lot happiness a lot
i think this is a thick boy finale
and other than that final beat at the
end it didn't feel
particularly rushed or too much to me
i i quite enjoyed the
chaos of it all
i
left me with a couple questions though
like what
so we saw in oblivion that five got his
arm cut off right
but then the reboot happened but he got
a tattoo so i'm like
is that like an offshoot of the events
of what happened in oblivion because he
still got his arm cut off and still got
the tattoo but he's in the
the paradox proof panic room
that's a good question
[Laughter]
i don't know if that makes sense i don't
know if it tracks
well i i mean i think there's a reason
they set up the whole thing about a
paradox
yeah no i imagine they'll probably come
into season four because the thing with
paradoxes is you go
wait if this didn't happen how did this
happen how did this happen if this
didn't happen you know when they when i
forget i forgot what episode it was like
three or episode three or four
when they were explaining what a paradox
is and i think that's part of it is like
i don't know how well they can explain
that but maybe the events of oblivion
did happen
but it but but when they went to
that point in the time stream lila and
five
that
there's still a plane of existence of
earth
do you know what i'm getting at like
they're still in existence
so
the universe wasn't done with
yeah there's well is the
do we know that the time bureau exists
within this plane of reality
i don't know i don't [ __ ] remember
man
i watched it two years ago just roll
with it it's real fine fine but
yeah i i think that um
yeah leaves us with a lot of questions
just with uh i don't know how klaus came
back i have no [ __ ] clue
it doesn't make sense but i liked it i
like that he's back there needed to be
some type of physical body yeah cause
then all the times we saw him die he
like would return to that body and it
would like fix itself but you just
reanimate yourself out of nothing that's
that's interesting okay we're like ah we
wanted to make a strong choice but don't
question how how we go back on that
choice we just just roll with it
i'm
it didn't make sense but i was like okay
yeah i like this i like him i like them
together
doesn't mean it makes sense we're good
what's logic i don't know but i thought
the visuals were very beautiful
yeah
except for the uh
the the warrior guy with the holes in
his face it made me think maybe think of
like a like this actual condition where
like that's a thing you have like little
worms coming out of your face yeah
that's [ __ ] a real show it's how it
grows it's like there's a lot of
metaphors that are [ __ ] flying all
over my head
holes in there cockroaches okay is is
stanley back is stanley still
what was the thing with his ear what was
that all about
somebody called mislead into thinking he
had some powers well yeah but that there
was never like a payoff in that mislead
i it's a it's a weird season it is
because it starts off with like the
sparrow academy and what is this
kugelblitz and then the last half is
very much about
the show seems to function at its best
when the the main focus is stop the
world from ending yeah i wonder if we if
we were to go back and watch the
beginning of season three if you can see
all of the through lines for where
they end up by the end of this season
because like at some points it feels
like they're just kind of like going
along and like making it up but in other
points like okay there is a point to
what is happening like they like i still
don't understand why grace was so
obsessed with the
the things like she's a robot why is she
obsessed with yeah they have some story
lines that kind of
seem to
the idea with
the season usually is like a bunch of
different story lines and you watch the
convergence of it
and here was kind of just some some of
it was kind of like
it was kind of zigzagging around all
over the place like some of it doesn't
quite make you feel that completion
um when you when you think about it as a
whole i really have two associations
with the season
the first half and the last half
i didn't hate the first time the last
half to me is very focused
and very concise and clear and powerful
and effective
and then the first half
they do feel like two separate halves
you know i mean yeah
like it's part of the same story but
execution wise they feel
like not as
properly tethered or even like the grief
of harlan kind of feels dropped for
victor
yeah
i feel like a lot of things
happened without
full payoff but like i said like i think
i said at the one of the earlier
episodes like things certain things
would kind of happen to further the plot
but without any real sense behind them
and then other things would make sense
but would also do that would make sense
for our characters whether where they
were emotionally and that elevated the
plot and i think this season had a mix
of both of those things so i still at
the end of the day it was still a very
enjoyable season of television to watch
but i think if we were comparing it to
the other two seasons of umbrella
academy i still think it falls third for
me
it does uh it does but it still has some
of
the most memorable in a in a very
extremely positive way has some of the
most memorable moments of umbrella
academy for me yeah definitely like one
million percent and yeah it
there there are some like character beat
stuff like that i do kind of wish we had
that would have created more conflict
like i i think sloan
you know like once when sloan first
loses those members of the sparrows
she's just she's so upset and then it's
just she's not upset anymore
and and victor and harland i'm like
i feel like that would create some real
like it seemed like victor was just so
focused on like i'm mad at you allison
for the way you treat me like there's a
real loss here yeah they never give her
a chance to really process that early
like cece was the love of your life and
that was cece's kid and harlan was
killed and you know like there was a
yeah like it and it didn't
in this whole thing with um
harlan
[Music]
kind of
like harlan gives up his powers but for
some reason that storyline doesn't
feel like it mattered amounted to much
no because it was such a big part of the
first half yeah cause like you can do
one of two things i it either
power victor up enough to
to
be
something that's that's more um
exponential in in their ability
or it could serve as something that
really uh boosts harlan as a character
or or
connects those two but i don't i don't
think that
if you take harlan out of the show
it changes a lot i mean me it's the
catalyst for their rel the rift between
alice and allison and victor's
relationship but
outside of that i don't know if it did a
whole lot i mean it started it started
the the cougar blicks and like the the
paradox of that but
yeah he didn't at the end of the day he
didn't do much as a character and i was
i was kind of looking forward to
what he was going to do also we don't
know why his name is like it's important
but somehow still feels incomplete yeah
yeah like i said like there's a lot of
stuff i enjoyed about umbrella academy
because like at the end of the day i
still enjoy all these characters but
there were some some loose threads and
some some things in there that didn't
quite make sense like i still don't
understand what the whole buffalo thing
was it just like a physical
representation to show that this was the
other half of a dimension or the other
side of a a portal door was there more
significance to that
sure
yeah these were a lot of questions but i
can say that at the end of the day i did
enjoy watching this i had a really fun
time doing this with you and i think
that i like i'm gonna continue to watch
the show yeah and i love lila a lot on
this you know like lilo was such a in
the previous mischievous villain
and then here i i quickly bought her as
one of the main protagonists yeah like
not a villain at all like like no you're
you're one of the good ones yeah
did did ben work for you by the end of
the season
he's all right
i didn't love ben but yeah but i didn't
mind ben by the in the last few episodes
in the last few i didn't mind him yeah i
went from like hating him to like
tolerating him
yeah to being like he's fine
yeah
and they also never really go into the
the whole jennifer thing with him sure i
was hoping they would because you see
all the pictures and art they kind of
allude to it without really diving in
deep which i'm like yeah yeah
yeah there's a lot of there's a lot of
stuff that they just do for the sake of
doing without following through i mean
there's a lot to appreciate though i
mean i think i do i think the finale i
love the setting of
i feel like there's still more to
explore yet i still really like the
execution of having this sort of ominous
horror tone
like it was suspenseful it was it was
really like when they started walking
through
you know like different when the hotels
kind of turning in on them yeah it was
cool yeah like that was that was intense
that was that was really suspenseful it
was pretty cool
and uh
i really like yeah i really like that a
lot and
and uh
yeah that was fine
klaus
you do see how his powers do come like
he was able to just kind of like summon
luther yeah so the button kind of that's
what i mean there's a lot happening
there because like luther's dead he's in
the afterlife they get back there luther
gets to save the day say goodbye to
sloane and it's a ghost and oh it's sad
and then
and and and then um and then he's back
he's back it's like weird hey come here
yeah
yeah um like
i guess in some ways some things could
have used a bit more breathing room but
in the immediacy of the moment it wasn't
feeling rushed to me
and
kind of reflecting i'm like yeah maybe
it could have been a little longer to
help let some things kind of
pace out a little bit better um but i i
do think that overall this was still
like it still gets me excited to come i
still i'm still excited for season four
and i still want to uncover
what's gonna happen in season four i
want to see the completion of the story
yeah i would hate for it to end here
no yeah yeah i would hate for like it
could end here i would think that would
suck though if it ended here i'm like no
we gotta see
we gotta see what happens i think that'd
be a terrible final scene
oh okay i guess it was just a really
really downer note yeah like whatever
wins and they all separate
yeah there is something really odd about
the way that final
moments played out to me but
i'm gonna use a little bit they didn't
ever quite have that scene
like there tends to be like like a cool
like a great sequence that just stands
out you know what i also realized there
was never like
they're the umbrella academy but there's
never like that team moment you know
like how they had in season two i still
think season two is the strongest season
of the show definitely i i agree i i
know a couple people who prefer season
one overall
um but no season two for me is still my
personal favorite i would say the
strongest i would have liked to
to watch them
work together as like he said we need
the seven or seven of them to do this
and granted they were they all seven for
standing on the pieces so the machine
would work but i would like to see seven
of them or all of them
work with their powers together all
avengers style or justice league style
you know to try to take down whatever
these threats were
but i guess at the end of the day it's
it's not really
a superhero show in spite of the fact
that
the premise started with
these siblings that were
formed to originally be a superhero
team yeah yeah i mean
i think what makes this show charming is
oddities it's gonzo nature it's
it's like when it just leans into its
weirdness and absurdity
yeah you know like it's not it's not the
weirdest season
there's something that's kind of like
unsettling in the last like there's
something that's kind of like unsettling
it's more melancholic
what i respect about this show a lot is
i can say each season feels very
different 100 and i think that's a
really cool thing to say is they they
all feel different yeah you know kudos
to them or not like the first one felt a
little bit more gothic
yeah gothic kind of grounded you know
like yeah before they really like upped
their budget you know they had to like
really rely on all the character drama
in the first season and then the second
one was like that 60s backdrop
and uh it got really weird with it more
fun and exciting
and this had more of uh
an acceptance of death
you know dealing with that
and but
it yeah the tone flair didn't start
really clicking for me until the last
half yeah but there's a yeah there's a
lot about the mood this is like the dark
knight rises out of the trilogy movie
yeah yeah
you know where i'm like there's a lot
visually and tonally that i really love
about this one and there's some really
exciting stuff but i definitely feel
like it's the the third one
yeah
yeah i want a more pogo man i liked
biker pogo which we got to see more of
his life and more of his involvement
with the family and what his
relationship was with the sparrows
yeah this is not the most fulfilling
season i would say i keep going back to
things that are just adjectives of
feeling a little incomplete in some
arenas
yeah i like like i said i i know a lot
about i was like man dude [ __ ] this
the last half you should have gone to
like this [ __ ] a little faster mm-hmm i
don't i didn't feel like we needed to
get to take that long to get to that
especially when they're like yeah
sparrows don't really [ __ ] matter
i
yeah and um when when the when they set
you up for that and you're just like a
screw it um so
that's why i said i feel like you didn't
really have a little clear vision it's a
little disjointed in that regard and i
feel like the last half is so much
better and so good
but because they only have a certain
number of episodes to do
you know it's like if they had just done
the plot line that the episode five and
more and on introduces or episode six
and on truly introduces if that was the
like more of the focus and jumping point
instead of any of this like sparrow
academy [ __ ] and like
you know what it felt like to me it felt
like at the end of season two they wrote
themselves into a hole and it took them
yeah they were like six episodes to
figure out how the [ __ ] they were
getting themselves we don't really want
to do this sparrow
we're gonna change ben's hair we're not
gonna make the sparrows matter all that
much we're gonna make some full
characters but uh we just want to get to
this point and by any means necessary
we're gonna get there yeah they felt
very disposable
they literally were like harlan killed
two of them
like nothing i don't remember how raven
lady died i just felt like google blitz
things google blitz you got blitz and
then so did christopher yeah right
well there's a lot to enjoy about the
season but there's a lot that kind of
annoyed me and aggravated me as well but
like i don't know it's like it it needs
to like somehow thematically play in or
emotional wise play in yeah and then you
know what also something is like i said
they would do things without actually
um
making them fully matter like the whole
conversation about that five had with
with uh victor about
doing if you do things alone like you
become the villain and like if you do
that [ __ ] again i'll kill you myself now
like that never really came back into
play yeah that's what i mean is is they
set up a lot of really that's what i
mean is like if the last half was the
first
five episodes essentially and then they
had five more to expand
like you get to the apocalypse ending at
the very end
of that
different alternate timeline 10 that i'm
talking about in my own head cannon
then then they they really could have
had like a pretty perfect season three
that feels like really doom and gloom
and melancholic and because i really
loved like i i loved at least three of
these episodes there was at least three
episodes i truly loved in here
and
like seven eight and nine i thought were
like i love them and 10's a pretty damn
great finale it's just
because it's a finale it gets you to
kind of look at the whole picture
and uh i thought it was good
i thought i thought the family was good
i don't think i loved it as much as you
but i liked it a lot yeah i was
surprised by how much i liked it i
thought they were going to drop the ball
[Music]
i think six seven and eight were my
favorites six seven and eights were the
ones that i absolutely loved
six again what happened
six is when i was like that was really
good and then 789 and i was like these
are awesome i started yeah you started
to flip around in six i think six is
when
harlan got killed
uh that's five
no it's six no
was it six pretty sure there was six
i only got
at the very end of five i know six is
when lila and diego first go into the
oblivion i don't remember how it ends
but six is when i really felt like this
is a turning point i remember feeling
like this is a turning point but seven
was when i was like wow that was great
yeah and eight was like oh my god they
did it again
and i really i really liked episode nine
a lot i thought episode 9 was pretty
awesome it got me jazzed about the
finale yeah episode 9 was really good
yeah i really liked the the the wedding
episode i think that was uh the most
heartfelt for me i was eight yeah
and that's what i mean like those tones
they mastered here that seven and eight
like that real
like they never really became as fun as
like season two but in terms of like
going into this
like the
this this feeling of
death and appreciating
just your loved ones and the ones you
live with yeah so that's why i mean like
the ending
kind of like
undercuts a lot of that for me here i
just like [ __ ] got by i'm like
[Laughter]
it would have been more powerful if
there was some type of emotion to them
separating
if they had time to just like have like
luther could go off but it's like what
do we do and they instead of just being
like uh
in some ways it's very umbrella academy
but i feel like for a finale it it i i
would have personally preferred a bit of
an emotional button like they still
could have separated
but i would have liked it more if there
was some type of emotional undercurrent
to them going their separate ways yeah
i'll say in some ways for me emotionally
this season season three of umbrella
academy is like the emotional equivalent
of like stranger things season two for
me
so i think the only thing i think series
of things three is my least favorite
really i really enjoyed season three the
the action like the uh the blockbuster
season
i dug it
i ran whenever we watched them i was
like threes a week
that's a pretty four is killing it
four's killing there's a reason four
feels nothing like three
but hey maybe umbrella academy had that
same luck with the with a killer season
four you know a focus season four
they're never gonna give them that much
money you know what i think if
i'm happy
i didn't i really enjoyed the journey of
how we got here i wasn't over head over
heels in love with it like it was season
two but i think
where we end the season gives us a lot
of potential for them to
really shine and really do something
creative and new going forward because
they haven't they haven't written
themselves into a immediate action kind
of cliffhanger yeah they can do a time
job if they want to to help figure
things out and and us find these
characters in these new places
um
until something else ultimately has to
bring them back together yeah i think
season one and two did a great job but
like what are our starting points for
our characters in the first and second
episode and then what is the completion
by the end yeah i think and here i'm
like oh that first five feels very
different and their and their arcs don't
feel
that
clear
as a unit or as individuals yeah and
weirdly enough in some ways
if they play it right
this almost is like um
like a reprisal or like uh
some because at the end of the beginning
how the series starts with everybody
separated you know so where we end this
third season is everybody disperses
again right so the fourth season gives
them the opportunity for them to all be
in those places what are their lives for
them some sort of event to have to bring
them back together again right
what is the audience score on this
season
oh yeah i don't want too many people
that watched it either i have like one
it's not getting as many i don't think
it's getting as many views as the
previous season i wonder why that is
um
i'm going to check the audience score
here
because for stranger things was gone
longer than the umbrella academy was and
then they're firing all cylinders as far
as views and audience ratings go it's
[ __ ] stranger things
like completely different beasts the
flagship show of netflix i mean the
reviews are really high for season three
this is 90
wow that's very high is it higher than
season 102 i mean season two is 91
percent season two is great
season two has ah like 40 more reviews
so that's pretty good season one is the
lowest
of the critic reviews fascinating
the audience scores pretty low it's 62
for this season
yeah huh
um
[Music]
yeah i mean
don't know
it doesn't matter either way i enjoyed
it yeah this is kind of fascinating now
62 it was pretty low
it's like right on the edge of passing
god damn um but i haven't dived in to
see the opinions but that is pretty low
because i think season two is like 89 or
something um it's a great season that's
great this is the best one
uh yeah guys thank you for being here
thanks aaron for joining me thank you
for having me it's been a pleasure
interesting enough to leave on and hey
uh
stick around for whatever more we decide
to cover appreciate y'all much love
reject nation glad we gotta complete
this journey
you